calvin lucian leads the kill squad team
through the mud and freezing rain
in front of them looms the fortress of
baron lehman hoadley
the eighth overseer the team has already
been through a lot
from breaking the overseer council's
deal with death by eliminating 05-13
to using the spear of the non-believer
to kill the godlike archivist
05-10 the hunting of overseers has taken
a toll on the kill squad
oh 5-12 almost killed adam and olivia
was stuck in what seemed like an
endless mind game with 05-11 the first
five overseers were eliminated
but the words that the ninth overseer
spoke to calvin lucien before she died
still
run through his mind are you afraid of
death
now the kill squad is about to
infiltrate one of the most heavily
guarded facilities in the world
to eliminate the eighth overseer upon
reaching the castle
the team is surprised to find the
structure is in ruin
no one is supposed to know the location
of 05-8 though
the fortress was supposed to be
practically impregnable
they stormed the castle of 05-8 all the
same the journal calvin possesses that
contains
information about the members of the scp
foundation's powerful 05 council
identifies him as a former industrialist
named baron lehmann-hodley
with his vast wealth holdly funded the
foundation at the start
and was considered the unofficial leader
of the council in its early days with
immense control
over the actions of the organization the
kill squad makes their way through the
dimly lit hallways of the castle
as they turn the corner they are
surprised to find the charred remains of
baron lehman hoadley's bodyguards
it seems that someone or something has
gotten too hodly before they could
the team makes their way to the main
chamber and breaches the door
laying by a still-lit fireplace is 05-8
the kill squad scans the room to make
sure the killer isn't still in there
with them
adam walks over to the body and examines
it he quickly realizes that hodley
hasn't been murdered at all
he sees that baron holdly's body has
been drastically modified using
anomalous technology
the overseer used his immortality to
modify almost every part of his body to
make himself stronger
unfortunately for baron hoadley when the
overseer's deal with death was broken by
calvin
the modifications to his body slowly
tore him apart
his regular body could no longer support
all the modifications
and what once made him practically
invincible became the very thing
that destroyed him the team leaves the
castle and crosses 05-8 off their list
on their way out adam pulls calvin aside
he has the feeling that anthony hasn't
been completely honest with the rest of
the team
he had the feeling that anthony was
hiding something from them
calvin had similar thoughts recently he
pushes anthony for more information
about his past
and anthony reveals that he's over 100
years old
the vial of water from the fountain of
youth that calvin has was not the only
one
early in his career with the insurgency
he had confiscated
other vials from a foundation site his
squad drank the water
and it extended their lives he asks
calvin
what he plans on doing with his water
from the fountain i'm going to destroy
it
calvin tells him anthony agrees with his
plan
once you drink from the fountain of
youth you may extend your
life but a part of you dies at the same
time
vibrancy of the senses disappears
leading to a seemingly shallow life
if anthony could go back and do it again
he never would have drank the water
calvin receives intel from the
insurgency that the seventh overseer is
in a small town in cambodia
the kill squad makes their way to the
village and surveys the area
hoping to get a glimpse at the overseer
who's codenamed
green as the team conducts
reconnaissance anthony tells them that
he thinks the mission is a setup
it is too remote and there are so many
unknown variables
but calvin is convinced that this might
be their only chance to kill green
since green arrived in the area there
has been non-stop chaos
she has destabilized the local
governments and now the area is in an
all-out war
the team weaves through narrow
passageways between houses and buildings
trying to make their way to the central
compound where green is located
suddenly a mob starts to form they are
getting closer and closer to the team
in a quick decision to avoid being seen
calvin orders everyone
into a nearby building before anthony
can follow the mob rounds the corner
they spot anthony and he's forced to
flee calvin olivia and adam watch as the
mob chases after anthony
but they have to keep moving calvin
knows that anthony can take care of
himself
and they are too close to their goal to
stop now calvin slowly
opens the front door of the house they
are hiding in and peers out
the coast looks clear so he signals
olivia and adam to follow him
before they can step out into the street
a gas canister enters through a crack
doorway
the room fills with sleeping gas and the
team passes out
when they are awake they are tied up in
a large room with marble vaulted
ceilings
05-7 is standing in front of calvin she
smiles wickedly while holding a knife
she compliments calvin on what he and
his team have been able to do
so far no one believed they could pull
off even a fraction of what they have
but now she has an offer for calvin she
points towards adam and olivia
and tells calvin he must choose one of
them to die if he doesn't
she'll kill the leader of the rioters
and plunge another part of the country
into chaos
screw you is calvin's response very well
utter screen have it your way she
assassinates the leader being held in
her compound
then turns back to calvin she now
threatens to torture his team until
calvin makes a choice of who to kill
green slashes adam's cheek with her
knife as kelvin screams for green to
leave his team alone and torture him
instead
green just smiles i'm going to enjoy
killing your friends while you watch as
you have killed
so many of my overseers on the council
she reaches up in the air with a knife
above adam's head
before she can plunge the knife through
his skull a bullet passes through her
hand
causing her to drop the knife anthony
kneels on a rooftop across the courtyard
smoking sniper rifles still pointed at
green who runs
calvin uses the drop knife to cut his
ropes and chases after green
he follows her to the roof where he
watches as she boards a helicopter
the aircraft lifts off as anthony fires
at it from his original position
but does no serious damage in the plaza
below
the mob that has separated the team
earlier becomes restless
there is complete chaos and someone
fires a rocket at the fleeing helicopter
the rocket hits the tail of the aircraft
sending it crashing into the plaza full
of rioters below as the crowd flees from
the scene
calvin makes his way towards the
wreckage and reaches it at the same time
anthony does
calvin looks at him smiles and thanks
him for saving his life
anthony smiles back but before he can
say anything
a gunshot rings out and a bullet rips
through his neck
calvin turns to see where it came from
and is horrified to see the burning body
of 05-7
her skin has been charred black but in
her burnt hand
she holds a gun what's left of her lips
curled back in the sinister grin
as she fires again and hits anthony in
the chest
he falls to the ground kelvin runs to
him and pulls out his gun to shoot 05-7
but she is already dead calvin holds his
dying teammate as blood pours out of his
neck
and chest but calvin can stop this he
pulls out the vial of water from the
fountain
no one says anthony i have lived long
enough
thank you my friend i will see you in
whatever lies beyond this life
anthony's chest rises then falls it does
not rise again
olivia and adam round the corner to see
calvin holding the lifeless body of
their teammate
tears flowing from his eyes the team
holds a small ceremony and burial for
anthony
but are only halfway through their
mission and can't stop now
they fly back to the united states where
an undercover insurgency agent named
kowalski informs them that 05-6
is already aware they're after him this
overseer is code named the american
because he has the power of the entire
us military at his fingertips
the kill squad scouts the base where the
american is located
kowalski warns them of a crate that was
recently brought to the base from site
19.
the americans showed great interest in
whatever was in the container
the group sets up a camp on a hill
overlooking the base
as the sun slowly rises the next day the
kill squad is spotted by a drone and
forced to hop in their jeep and try to
run
they make their way down the hill
finding themselves in the valley below
with no clear exit
in front of them lands a helicopter as
humvees roar into the canyon behind them
the team is surrounded a jeep pulls up
and 05-6 steps out he introduces himself
as rufus king
member of the overseer council but an
american citizen
first and foremost all he really wants
is to protect the country he loves
thanks to you i've lost my immortality
and can no longer
effectively protect the united states
anymore the american says to kelvin
but i'm willing to make a deal your
freedom for the spear of the
non-believer
rumor has it that you have the spear in
your possession and you used it to kill
the
archivist you give me the spear i will
let you go
no replies calvin i will never give an
overseer the means to cause more
destruction
the spear stays with us very well
the american says with a frown then i
suppose my only other option is to take
it from you
but not without giving you a fair chance
run
calvin lucian run as fast as
you can i will be coming
for you the american turns and walks
towards the container from site 19
which is being lowered from a helicopter
hovering above them
calvin sprints back to the jeep with the
other members of his team
as they drive away they hear a horrible
guttural screech from whatever was
inside the container
after a few moments the army begins to
pursue them
out in front of the military force is
05-6 writing
scp-682 he is using a black whip to urge
the creature forward
and they're gaining on the kill squad
fast
a row of vehicles pulls up beside the
american and scp-682
then something strange happens a man
appears in front of the oncoming forces
led by the american
the man's skin bulges and seems to be
moving from within
the skin of the man sloughs from his
body the infection that is
scp-610 erupts out of him and onto the
soldiers in the nearby jeep
scp-610 begins to infect and consume
everyone around it
suddenly there are thousands of
instances of scp-610 coming from the
mountainside
flooding into the valley they close in
and around the army and 05-6
the american begins fighting off the
flesh-eating creatures from the back of
scp-682
but he becomes overwhelmed he can no
longer focus on pursuing calvin and his
team
from the back of the jeep olivia pulls
out her rifle she aims
and fires the bullet hits the american
in the chest
he is flung off the back of scp-682
and engulfed in a sea of scp-610
creatures
the kill squad continues to drive trying
to put as much distance between
themselves and the scp-610 infestation
as possible
but then calvin suddenly slams on the
brake standing in front of them
is a man in a black suit and bow tie he
introduces himself as
blackbird the fifth overseer according
to the journal
his actual name is mortimer j denning
von krucnicker
he stands in front of the jeep with a
menacing grin
you have been causing a lot of trouble
he says looking at calvin
olivia swings her gun around oh please
my dear that won't help you
von krocnecker says he pulls out a knife
and stabs himself through the neck
he falls to the ground apparently dead
there is a gust of wind
a whiff of ozone and an identical copy
and still very much alive on krucniker
lands next to his own dead body
see what i mean he says olivia lowers
her rifle
come with me i have something to show
you the blackbird beckons
seeing no other option calvin olivia and
adam exit the jeep and followed the
blackbird
as they walked the world changes around
them the desert mountains fade away into
blackness and find themselves in the
near apocalyptic london
oh it's good to be home the blackbird
says as they emerge onto a cobblestone
street
you cannot stop the overseer's plans
however i can
give you an alternative let's see if any
of you will take it
in front of each kill squad member
appears a door
they have an uncontrollable urge to open
their respective door and walk through
the blackbird stands smiling as he
watches calvin olivia
and adam enter each of their portals
adam enters his door and looks around
he is in portland his parents walk into
the room
in this universe his family has been
granted asylum
adam never has to interact with any scps
or the foundation
he is free to live a normal life from
the kitchen comes calvin wearing an
apron
he is holding a steaming pot adam locks
eyes with calvin who smiles at him
the blackbird whispers into adam's ear
in this reality both of your parents and
siblings are still alive
also the man you love loves you back
you and calvin could be married if you
stayed here wouldn't that be nice
olivia enters her door she is on the
deck of a yacht
at the bose sits an easel with art
supplies the man that olivia once loved
walks across the deck towards her
the blackbird looms over her in this
reality you didn't
accidentally kill him this could be your
happily ever after
wouldn't that be nice calvin steps
through his door
he's in a grassy clearing near a lake
the blackbird hisses in calvin's ear
i'm giving you the opportunity to save
your mother this time
calvin you were just a scared little boy
but in this reality you can be brave
you can actually save your mother from
her faith no calvin screams
this isn't real the blackbird cackles
calvin looks away from the lake and
towards the tree line
hidden in the shadows he can just barely
make out a hooded figure
calvin walks towards it the blackbird
follows he is screaming at the person in
the tree line
i was only trying to help the hooded
figure reaches out and hands calvin a
metal tube
he opens it to find a set of eyeglasses
inside
calvin puts them on and turns to look at
the blackbird he steps back
in horror the glasses have revealed the
true form
of the blackbird he is a winged
pseudo-avian monstrosity
full of rage the mysterious hooded
figure directs calvin to open the tube
again
inside is an interdimensional fishing
line made by dr wondertainment
and a white wiffle ball bat calvin grabs
the fishing line and wraps it around
05-5's leg
the blackbird flies into the air trying
to get away from calvin
but calvin wraps the other end of the
fishing line around his arm
the blackbird begins to jump from
dimension to dimension trying to get rid
of calvin
they appear on the deck of scp-455 in
site-19 where scp-682 walks freely
in the dead world of scp-2935
every time they stop in a new dimension
calvin takes the opportunity to attack
the blackbird with the bad
and it seems that he is slowly weakening
the monster
they finally land at the bottom of a
deep well foundation containment site
where the dark body that is scp-001
is contained standing in front of the
containment field is alison
cho the black queen whose sole mission
is to destroy the foundation
you cries the blackbird you are the one
who's been helping lucian the black
queen nods her head
yes i have been helping calvin lucian to
eliminate you
and the other overseers the foundation
must
fall you are nothing you cannot stop me
i am the black king screams 05-5
alison chow sighs she pushes a button on
the panel next to her
shutting down the array containing the
dark body out of the cloud of dust
appears scp-001
a massive black creature who seemed to
absorb all
light no stop shrieks the blackbird
scp-001 does not move but the room
begins to shake
the blackbird continues to scream as his
body folds in on itself
until he is reduced to a single
superheated point
and then blinks out of existence alison
chow
then reactivates the containment array
ceiling zero zero one away
once again i will return you to your
reality along with your friends
says the black queen but perhaps our
path shall cross again
calvin lucian there is a bright flash of
light and calvin finds himself on a
private jet sitting next to olivia
and adam they are all shaken but the
blackbird
is dead 05-5 has been eliminated
the three members of the team sit
silently still
pondering what might have been if they
stayed in the alternate realities
suddenly the phone on the plane begins
to ring breaking
silence calvin picks it up on the other
line is the fourth overseer
he has contacted calvin to discuss
surrendering to the insurgency
unfortunately things do not always go
as planned calvin lucian is about to
make the most difficult
and dangerous decision of his life
[Music]
you